geraldine uriel needed the equivalent of
500 euros to buy this dairy cow
a normal bank would never have approved
a loan but thanks to 36
investors from around the world she
raised the money
now she earns a living selling her cow's
milk and has already paid off her debts
she recently organized a second micro
credit
i took out a loan of 100 000 kenyan
shillings and used it to buy 250
chickens
in two weeks time they'll start laying
eggs then i can sell them
and earn about 2 000 shillings a week
the business that facilitated her loan
is based in the kenyan capital nairobi
mad kier from denmark launched the
online social lending platform
my c4 in 2006.
it matches people who have money with
those who need it
on friday but this one is actually too
high so it's 100 funded
how my c4 works is that there's a
competition between the lenders
about what interest rate they will bid
in principle you can lend your money out
at zero percent interest
then you don't earn anything but you can
relent it and re-lend it when you're
getting repaid
but you could also choose an interest
rate do you want to make money or you're
a social investor or maybe you're both
mad kier sees himself as a social
entrepreneur
but he also has his eye on the bottom
line one third of the interest on the
loans goes to my c4
for now kiara partly funds his business
out of his own pocket
he runs the care group set up by his
father
yes we lent about 4 million
euros out in 2013 and that paid half of
our costs
so if we can double that to 8 million
euro it will pay all of our cost and we
will be a business making a profit
so that's target 1 target 2 is to grow
much more
i mean you have more than 100 million
people living in kenya uganda and
tanzania that's a huge market
today kiara is on his way to kiambu 20
kilometers north of nairobi
he's meeting one of my c4's local
partners
their input is valuable to the business
they know many of the platforms users
personally
in the early days the business saw heavy
losses
but madskyr has learned from the
mistakes
that was one of the reasons why we
failed yes we did it from denmark
so that was of course also extremely
expensive that we had to fly down and
you know stay in hotels and
uh didn't make any sense and we didn't
have the local knowledge like eric and
kevin and the team has
together with daniel kimani who heads
the regional office
he's developing a further aspect of the
company
the plan is to allow lenders to invest
not just in individuals but also in
groups
for every loan that we are coming to
land it must have been approved by the
group
the group must have given a guarantee
remember this group
for them to be assessed to be ready for
wrongs they must also show
ability to raise some retro money of
their own which they manage on their own
these funds it is correctively agreed
within the group
they would be used to help any of their
members
if they are struggling to pay the loans
380 million people in africa have no
bank account
that means they can't get loans
peter lawrence is one of them but now
he's the owner of three offices for
mobile money transfers
his loan is guaranteed by a group
as far as mods care is concerned he's a
model entrepreneur
it's doing great i have a quite good
turn up of the customers under the
challenges i'm able to meet
to compare challenges with some
intervention that i'm doing some
strategies like
customer service i'm being late peter
you know i've been working 30 years in
africa
and why we created myc4 and the
partnership was with keith
was to fund businesses like you so you
could grow yeah because the banks
doesn't want to go there and you
you want to borrow more than a
microfinance institution normally lend
out
yeah and they want to collateralize
everything yeah and you actually don't
have that
yeah but you have a group and that makes
me very proud to see how you're growing
back in the outskirts of nairobi
geraldine uriel is on her way to the
fields
her two loans allowed her to lease more
land and she now grows corn
potatoes and bananas
this is my land now half a hectare of
agricultural land
now i can afford to pay for my two
children to go to school and my life is
much better
social lending has made geraldine oreo a
successful businesswoman